[Music]
what is it that the left gets wrong
about ethnic minorities where would I st
they can't comprehend that there may be
racial tensions which don't involve
white people and and I think
that you know which coming from Luton
and being raised there I find Bonkers if
you just look at you know providing
anti-discrimination protections on the
grounds of race ethnicity and religion
Britain comfortably outperforms other EU
countries Euro falls in the UK they look
at the EU has this sort of almost like a
sort of Haven of Tolerance and openness
have they never been to France
well and and I think especially a real
problem is middle class progressivism in
in in modern day Britain because these
are these are people who I think they
almost use racial identity Politics as a
way to deflect attention from their own
position of socio economic privilege I
don't think race is the influential
determinant of Life chances that many
people portray it to be what is
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin kiss and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific guest today returns
to the show for the second time uh to
talk about his new book beyond grievance
what the left gets wrong about ethnic
minorities Ry Bean welcome back thank
you for having me again it's great to
have you on the show you've written this
book uh looking forward to talking about
it before we do remind everybody who are
you uh your background how are you
talking about this stuff and how did you
get here no sure so um without blowing
my own trumpet too much I'm an expert my
background's in Social cohesion um race
relations in matters uh surrounding
integration as well and those are kind
of themes that I talk about a great deal
um in my book beyond grievance what the
left gets wrong about ethnic minorities
and I'd say that my general interest you
know living most of my life in Luton is
how do you cultivate shared values a
sense of common purpose in a hyper
diverse Society because the reality is
in my view diversity is not an
unadulterated good by any stretch of the
imagination and it's only a strength
really if you can tie that together as I
said you know with those shared values
Mutual obligations and a sense of common
purpose and those are the kind of
Concepts that I really um tackl in the
new book can I just say before we jump
in right is that if I had come on here
and I said that I'm an expert in racial
integration mate it's got a little bit
of a different vibe yeah well I'm glad
you added that I mean very important so
Rak let's talk about uh what the left
gets wrong about ethnic minorities uh
and one of the things I actually want to
explore with you as well is we we've had
people you and people of a similar
mindset to you on the show many many
times as you know and I think certainly
in our world there's a cons ensus about
this issue the left gets lots of stuff
wrong about race relations and
minorities Etc and yet the big cities in
this country where which are minority
you know heavily popul strong ethnic
minority populations well London I think
is now what 30 something per so I think
it's around just over one in three
residents in London um are white British
right so if the left is so wrong about
ethnic minorities why do they keep
voting for leftwing
parties I think it's a very good
question I think that that's largely a
failing of the conservative party I
think that for a long time it's had a
very problematic relationship with many
of the countries racial and ethnic
minorities and I think that stems back
from you know Powell's rivers of blood
speech uh for example and also there's
the smic byelection in the same decade
where the Tory candidate there main
slogan was if you want to for a neighbor
vote labor and I think people probably
know liberal or labor
I think people know what that um what
that racial slur was in that slogan and
I think it really takes time to really
rebuild those ties but I think that the
point is with the conservative party
they certainly have problems in terms of
how they engage with what I would
consider to be quite socially
conservative minorities and I just don't
think they've put the effort in I think
you have people on the right for example
who say you know London has fallen they
go into those London iston narratives
and all the rest of and actually if they
made bit more effort I think that they
could cultivate a good amount of support
in um traditional ethnic minority
communities which are quite family
oriented Community spirited they're
quite conservative when it comes to Law
and Order um and actually I think in the
last meral contest between S Khan and
sha Bailey I think the conservatives
didn't truly believe in their own
candidates so maybe they backed him up
with the time and resources that might
have been a different outcome it's a
really good point actually because there
was there was a moment where I thought
actually Sean stood a very good chance
of winning against sadik but the left
has also got its problems with ethnic
minorities in that there's this
narrative in the left that if you don't
vote for a left party in order to quote
a very famous philosopher you ain't
black no absolutely I mean we've seen
quasi Quang no fan of his Economic
Policy but there' have been uh
parliamentarians who refer to him as
superficially black you know so that
kind you know very divisive Notions of
you know racial authenticity I think
it's a real problem on the left and I
think that more generally if you look at
sadik Khan for example a lot of people
don't actually realize he's not that
popular in the capital especially with
ethnic minorities but I think the
question there is what is their
alternative and I think that's where the
conservative party they need to have
their own if you actually look at recent
electoral results some of the most
promising results that the conservative
party had at local level or in slow for
example slow is a majority non White
Town Leicester quite recently they've
made quite strong local gains on the
count on the council up there so if
you're actually seeing where the Tories
are performing quite well in recent
elections it's actually in more
ethnically and racially diverse parts of
the country that's really interesting so
uh coming back to the subject of your
book then uh what is it that the left
gets wrong about ethnic minorities where
would I start I I think they're getting
a lot wrong at the moment I think one
thing I really wanted to achieve with
the book is challenge wons to be Doom
and Gloom narratives surrounding the
lives of racial and ethnic minorities
and religious minorities as well uh in
the UK I think that there's a very good
number of identitarian activists which
regularly Get on um mainstream media and
I think they provide a grossly
inaccurate car caricature of life um in
Britain and I think what I wanted to do
with the book is actually say the
picture on the ground is is far more
positive whether it's you know having
strong attachments to British national
identity um you know performing well at
school um doing well in the labor market
uh a lot of people are still very
surprised when I tell them for example
that the one of the two of the highest
earning groups now in one day Britain
are workers of Chinese and Indian origin
um their average hourly pay um it
outperforms the white British mainstream
and I think when you're actually looking
at you know that sense of belonging um
Crest advisory did a recent study which
showed that three and four British
Muslims think that Britain is a good
place to live as a Muslim and I tell
people that and they're very surprised
and you have to ask why are they
surprised interestingly that figure
drops right down for non-muslims so
actually non-muslims are more likely to
think that Britain is an islamophobic
Society compared to British Muslims
themselves but those kind of narratives
I don't think get much exposure in the
mainstream media do you think part of
the problem is is that we've got these
whole these entire raft of political
commentators who get wheeled out on
these chat shows like Good Morning
Britain to essentially push forward this
narrative that Britain is close to Nazi
Germany and we a white supremacist
Nation well we've seen the was the
European research group in the
conservative prob be compared to Nazi
Germany and AP parid South Africa which
is just it's absolutely remarkable and I
think that more generally and I wouldn't
say that I look at Britain through roast
ined spectacles I still think there's
improvements to be made when it comes to
Racial equality I'm sure we'll discuss
that later on in the conversation but if
you just look at you know providing
anti-discrimination protections on the
grounds of race ethnicity and religion
Britain comfortably outperforms other EU
countries um such as you know France
Germany the Netherlands Spain and Italy
so you see post brexit Britain
outperforms a string of EU member states
where you have well consider Euro falls
in the UK they look at the EU as this
sort of almost like a sort of Haven of
Tolerance and openness have they never
been to France well and this comes to my
point that in France actually in France
you have that sort of Republican model
of you know colorblind egalitarianism
Lys which I consider to be a militant
form of secularism and what that's
actually produced is this mainstream
political culture which doesn't want to
acknowledge very real forms of racial
and religious discrimination now Britain
for all its flaws at least we have in my
view we have an infrastructure in place
which actually takes equality of
opportunity quite seriously I in my view
that the sort of discrimination in terms
of its salience as an issue shows in a
way Britain's commitment to providing a
more equal and fairer Society you don't
even have those debates in France so we
have the office for National statistics
which shows outcomes you know in terms
of racial and ethnic disparities you
don't even have that in France well I
mean that's not really a surprise like
Constantin said but so so let's talk
about what needs to be improved what do
we need to work on what are the areas
where we're not doing as well as we
should be when it comes to
integration I think that we have a
serious problem when it comes to
integrating newcomers in particular
parts of the country I think last year
we had the large scale public disorder
in Leicester for example which is
primarily between Hindu and Muslim
youths uh so I think the integration is
almost become a political orphan in a
way it doesn't get talked about as much
as it should by the two major political
parties I think we have a labor party
which talks a bit too much about
difference and celebrating that I think
the conservative party in a way just may
be paralyzed by its own history when it
comes to race relations not very
comfortable when it comes to talking
about matters of
integration um I think that in terms of
the improvements I'll give you an
example I think in the labor market um
names which are culturally distant maybe
Constantin kissing or raky ban for
example they tend to feir that bit worse
comp compared to traditionally English
sounding names I don't know maybe
Francis Foster for example so and you
and and that that holds up in a number
of studies even when you control for
work experience skills and educational
qualifications so something I argue for
in the book is that we need to have more
name blind applications in the labor
market people still ask but what happens
when you get to the interview they'll
see that you're Asian or black but at
least there you have the opport you have
more of an opportunity to get to that
stage and then you can prove yourself in
person I think that is an important be
an important development um I think in
terms of policing and it's a very
complex issue policing more generally I
think stop and search if the police
genuinely believes that this is an
effective instrument in terms of
combating knife crime it needs to
cultivate public support and communicate
more with local communities to say we
think this is genuinely needed and then
you can um police by public consent so I
think those kind of improvements would
be most welcome in my R can I ask you on
on the stop search thing because it's
kind of hard to know like you mentioned
that there's a media narrative about
islamophobia where non-muslims are more
persuaded by that narrative the Muslims
how true is it that uh ethnic minority
communities are outraged by the idea of
stop and SE because we've also had
people on the show who will tell you you
know you go to uh a community let's say
a black community area in London a lot
of the local population are really keen
on stop and search because it's their
children that are being stabbed oh no
absolutely I I think that when it comes
to stop and search more generally there
are disparities that's obvious but
ultimately if you're using that as an
instrument to fight knife
crime there's a degree to how equal you
can be when it comes to policing you
have to see where are the hot spots and
you know what are the how do you say the
socio demographic characteristics
associated with a particular form of
crime the reality is in London young
black males are disproportionally
represented among perpetrators and
victims of knife crime and and that
that's naturally going to guide the way
you police particular areas and I've
even said that you know maybe we should
have body warn cameras more widely in
the met so we just increase the sort of
accountability and responsibility when
it comes to policing but you're
absolutely right that when it comes to
Law and Order you'll find some of the
strongest conservative values all within
ethnic minority communities and you have
my own ethnic group um British
Bangladesh
they have one of the highest rates of
confidence in the local police force and
that's a Muslim majority ethnic group as
well by the way so I think that when you
actually look at Law and Order more
generally ethnic minorities Al They
ultimately want fairness but crucially
they care a great deal about the
security and safety of their local
communities if you really wanted to go
in the deep end and you wanted to talk
about support for the death penalty I'd
suspect actually be it'd be hiring many
ethnic and religious minority groups
compared to the more secularized white
British mainstream well definit
definitely it's such a good point cuz my
mom's an ethnic minority and she'd kill
about a third of this population if she
had her way you know so it's very true
they tend to be far more punitive when
it comes to Law and Order but I also
think that the way we talk about you
know talking about ethnic minorities
which encompasses Someone Like My Mother
who's a first generation immigrant from
South America and also for instance a
third generation immigrant from the
cariban or from West Africa let's talk a
little bit more in specific so what do
we know about each
group it depends on which metric you're
looking at I think firstly I'll make the
point that the Bame
acronym absolutely useless and redundant
in my view in terms of understanding the
reality on the ground in modern Britain
now people are trying to wheel out this
Global majority you know these kind of
phrases to try and replace it the
reality is that ethnic and racial
minorities then may be certain values
that they share across the board uh one
value that they'd often share is that
you know irrespective of which group you
belong to being an ethnic minority in
the UK you're far better position than
being an ethnic minority in other
countries such as France Germany and the
Netherlands um and the United States as
well something that um I touch upon in
the book but if you actually look at you
know educational performance how a
group's performing at school labor
market integration um trust in public
institutions there's a great deal of VAR
I between different ethnic and racial
minorities I'll give you one statistic
if you look at children aged up to 15
years um you know the rate of Lone
parent households that they live in the
rate of Lone parent households when it
comes to Children of that age um of
Indian origin it's 6% 6% live in Lone
parent households that goes up to 63%
for their peers of black Caribbean
origin so you can see there they would
all come under a collective Bame
umbrella term but you see there's huge
disparities there there's also huge
disparities when it comes to performing
um at school especially pupils of
Chinese origin if you were to compare
them with Gypsy Roma children huge desp
but they technically all fall under the
ethnic minority label and I think that
that that's the point I make that
actually you see that in on certain
social and economic metrics you have
nonwhite certain non-white ethnic
minorities performing better than the
white British mainstream which is why
I'm not sure how useful white privileged
theories are in the modern British
context but there's very clear
differences between those groups and
that's something I really wanted to
underline in the book because then that
moves the conversation towards what
helps to shape life chances in modern
day Britain in my opinion some people
may find this quite controversial I
don't think race is the influential
determinant of Life chances that many
people portray it to be and what is I
think family structure is is a huge one
for me you know the kind the values
which are cultivated in the household
the degree of family stability that's
not just family structure that's culture
what you're talking that's also culture
family structure and culture but there's
a degree of overlap Poss but I'm Keen to
emphasize that point because it's not
just about you know more people staying
together it's also about what are you
teaching your children exactly and and
that's very important and I think that
that also shapes your attitudes towards
marriage as an institution some people
may be more individualistic when it
comes to approaching marriage other
people might think well actually there's
a great deal of self-sacrifice required
here but I'm willing to take that on
that might be shaped by their faith or
their cultural values but I think there
is that overlap between family stability
and culture but crucially when it comes
to culture is for example how how is
education valued in the household if
you're looking at the local community
what are the markers of social status I
think we have some very problematic
subcultures in London if truth be told
which actually
glorify seem go as far as saying the
glorification of violence um hyper
materialism um and also cultural values
towards outer wedlock births one of the
strongest predictors of L parent
households whether not children are born
in wedlock or not now the reality is in
certain ethnic communities ethnic
minority communities having children
outside of marriage is is very
controversial it to be found upon in
other groups it's almost become the norm
if you're being absolutely honest I
think those kind of cultural Dynamics
they may be controversial and some
people may find it to be sensitive to
talk talk about but I do think that it's
worth having that conversation in terms
of how they shape life chances and the
pr and the progression of young people
more generally yeah well definitely
sorry Fran it's definitely the case
because I mean if you
want this is the what always bothers me
about this patronizing attitude to
ethnic minorities where it's
like no one actually cares about
outcomes people care about how good they
look saying things absolutely right
whereas if you actually care about
outcomes you would go well as you say
you know the the Bame acronym which is
ridiculous incorporates all sorts of
different groups with different sets of
behaviors and different outcomes so what
might we observe would be a good way to
behave and might we not suggest that
most people should behave that way do
you see what I mean but absolutely but
we don't have that conversation we don't
because I think there some people
they're Paralyzed by cultural and moral
relativism now let's be absolutely clear
certain cultural values in my view are
just better than other better than
others Bo that's that's the truth of it
right and and I think if you really and
I make this point if you really care
about young black lives especially in
inner city London you would talk about
family structure and Community culture
that little bit more in in in my opinion
and I think it's very interesting
because when you're talking about those
disparities that we're referring to
earlier if you look at um School
outcomes level of um education
attainment pupils of black African
origin are now performing better than
the white British mainstream
their co- racial peers of black
Caribbean origin are performing worse
than the white British mainstream so it
it can't be race it can't be simply a
matter of racial discrimination I mean
that that would be bizarre to suggest
that but we do have people who suggest
that and I think that's where you have
to look at sort of family values um
Community attitudes towards
education I think parental assertiveness
I think a lot of people talk about you
know children need to be you know they
need to be encouraged to be creative and
Innovative you know free thinking and
all the rest of it that's all well and
good but they need to have a strong base
there has to be that sense of discipline
and order in the household and there
needs to be an understanding that in my
opinion the mainstream I think there's
far too many parents who want to be
their their kids mate yeah right and and
listen my mom's my best friend but
there's also a clear understanding that
within that friendship there's a very
clear parent child relationship and
that's based on order and hierarchy now
those kind of terms sound very
oldfashioned and reaction ction but I
think they're necessary when it comes to
talking about you know keeping your
children on the on the straight and
narrow and making sure that they
progress well in life and I think that
these kind of debates on the left
they're they're shunned um if truth be
told a lot of these values are seen as
almost oppressive um and I don't I think
that's that's something that needs to
change I agree with you it needs to
change why is that why are we
so loath to engage in these types of
conversations when the reality is we all
know it's basic Common Sense well for us
we know its basic common sense but I
think that many people they' rather
they're more interested in appearing
virtuous in the public domain now I i'
I've never been interested in that as
you can probably tell um in truth be
told I get vilified for making some of
these
arguments and and I think especially a
real problem is middle class
progressivism in in in modern day
Britain because these are these are
people who I think they almost use
racial identity Politics as a way to
deflect attention from their own
position of socio economic privilege um
many people are actually insecure about
their privilege I just think listen
enjoy your privilege you know but but
don't you know don't get in the way of
effective social policy right and if you
are insecure about it I don't know maybe
see a therapist you know sort out sort
out yourself and I think the real
problem here is that what racial
identity politics does it it offers them
an opportunity to appear rebellious
without risking the destabilization of
their own class-based interests and
advantages when I think in my view the
left does still doesn't talk much
doesn't talk enough about class
class-based barriers we do live in a
fairly unequal country I think we should
make that point and and I think more
generally when you're looking at these
outcomes I've talked a great deal about
family structure Community Norms I think
geography comes to into it um I think
that there's many communities which are
predominantly WI British they're just
they're cut off they're isolated they're
Left Behind they're certainly not part
of the digital economy you could say and
and they're really lacking the sort of
social infrastructure you need in order
for young people to succeed and maximize
their potential so I think at the moment
we have this over focus on race and
we're largely overlooking in my view
very important factors factors which
shape life chances in modern Britain and
there's the familiar conversation that
we always have about white privilege
which has been like a lot of this stuff
imported directly from the states oh
absolutely you know just placed on this
country and you just go this Bears
absolutely no reflection on what is
really going on here well I've seen
blogs about white privilege published on
NHS websites which I just think is
absolutely remarkable because if you
travel around the country and you see
where the NHS is really crumbling it's
in those Left Behind import poish
predominantly white British communities
if you're going to go into those
communities and start lecturing them
about their racial privilege they're
just it's going to fall on death is or
actually they're going to find it quite
offensive and think I'm actually really
struggling in my local community here
and the NHS Services here are not
particularly good and and I think that
once again when it comes to those kind
of
theories um I think they're hugely
divisive but pseudo intellectualism it
doesn't really give you much of a
grounding to truly understand why those
ethnic and racial disparities exist um
in our country and I'll give you another
example if we've talked before about the
the various grooming gang scandals you
know people want to talk about power
structures you know structures of
Oppression all the rest of it you can
very clearly see where the power
dynamics lied in those
interactions um that very clear cases of
group-based child sexual abuse which are
also grossly Man mismanaged by public
institutions that prioritize political
correctness and racial and religious
sensitivities over the bread and butter
of protecting the most vulnerable
where's the presence of white privilege
in those particular cases I don't see
much evidence of
it we'll be back with the interview in 1
minute first we want to talk to you
about the sponsors of today's episode A1
we take ag1 to stay healthy and Stave
off illness whenever our schedule gets
really busy we used it on our last
America Tour where we were constantly on
the Move living out of a bag and working
every day one scoop a day meant we knew
we had all the vitamins and minerals
needed for the day we invested in our
health and had a hugely successful trip
as you saw ag1 is a simple and easy way
to get all the nutrients you need each
serving contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients if you're looking for a
simple and cost effective supplement
routine we recommend you try ag1 and
they're giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first person purchase to
claim them just go to drink a1.com
trigonometry go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink
a1.com
trigonometry to claim this special
offer R do you think that well you you
say that we live in an unequal country
and I think that inequality is actually
not race specific I mean there will be
outliers of course do you think we
underestimate how well we're doing uh
when it comes to race
relations uh having a very multi-ethnic
Society actually getting along uh
because most other parts of the world
when you have multiethnic societies you
kind of have to use a lot of violence to
keep things in check actually or
violence will erupt naturally we've
stayed away from that do you think we
underestimate how well we're doing I
think that there's lots of positives to
take I think that we've made significant
progress when it comes to race IAL
equality over the last 25 years the
majority of ethnic minority um people
according to a recent report published
by BR um British future which marked the
75th anniversary of win Rush um showed
that it was around two in three ethnic
minority people believe that we' made
significant progress when it comes to
Racial equality and four and five um
believe that you know when it comes to
being an ethnic minority it's better to
live in the UK compared to France
Germany and the United States and I
think it's really important to um
understand that and appreciate that
because many ethnic minority people as
you know they have family in those
countries as well so they have sort of
international family networks I'm sure
they have you know within my own family
Network we have discussions about these
kind of things um so and generally
ethnic minorities people make the point
that they're fairly well educated so
they're able to form their own
independent opinion on these issues it's
really interesting I flagged this data
and um in my view uh self hating pseudo
intellectuals of Twitter said oh but how
would they know they haven't lived in
those countries and all the rest of it
so sort of nice people's racism you know
the ethnic minority Brits they're not
able to formulate their own opinions
they don't fly anywhere
absolutely when actually they probably
fly more because the internationalized
nature of their family networks and and
I think that in terms of you know the
progress that we made I think that that
we should be proud of that that should
be a source of national pride but saying
that we did have you know for example
last year's large scale public disorder
in Leicester we've seen what's happened
in pekam as well yes with that um so
tell tell everybody because some of our
audience will absolutely so there's an
unfortunate incident at peckam hair and
cosmetics now it's obviously not a
establishment that I'm not familiar with
for obvious reason um but so essentially
it's it's an asian-owned business
there's a very interesting dynamic in
pekam where that there's far more um
black residents than Asian people that
live in the area and by the way just for
our American viewers sorry to interject
what you mean by Asian is people okay so
what I mean by Asian is people of
subcontinental Heritage South Asian
Heritage so we're talking about India
Pakistan Bangladesh Sri Lanka as well
those kind of countries um but what's
interesting that a lot of the businesses
that cater for the specific cultural
needs you could say for the uh for black
residents living in the area are
actually asian-owned
um so what happened unfortunately at
this establishment was that there was a
black lady
who was accused of um taking Goods that
she hadn't paid for apparently she was
upset with the um establishment's refund
uh policy and unfortunately this led to
a fiscal altercation with the um Asian
owner of of the business who who who who
is of a Muslim has a Muslim
background um and there's a great deal
of tension afterwards there were
protests Outside The
Establishment um and that included ra
racially motivated slurs being left on
the estab at the front of the um
establishment um go to hell
Patel um there there's a reference to
parasit parasitic Merchants have to be
rooted out the local community sort of
echoing the kind of vilification of
Asian business owners by Yamin um the
Ugandan dictator um who expelled Asians
only gave them 90 days before they could
um before they could leave the country
um
so I think when you look at those kind
of incidents it was very interesting for
me because I think the biggest thing
from the from that particular incident
was that it we had this sort of de facto
decriminalization of lower level crime
in many urban areas the country has a s
shoplifting epidemic um in my view and I
think that was the big takeaway from
that but you can see that people saw
that through a racial lens and that was
understandable because there have been
similar similar episodes in places such
as birming especially the lles area
where there's a great deal of
disillusionment you could say and I'd
say I'd go far saying resentment within
black communities especially of African
Caribbean Heritage there you know
businesses being bought up by Asian
origin entrepreneurs and that naturally
you know there's a shift in the sort of
ethnic and racial ownership of
businesses there and then there there
sort of accusations of you know most um
many of the shoplifters belonging to the
African Caribbean population um Asian
shopkeepers being accused of not
treating their black patrons and
customers um very well so you could see
that those kind of complaints emerged in
pekam um as well so I think it shows
that there are racial tensions which are
obviously involved but I think that the
the the broader or rather the central
problem for me is how there's a real
lack of local neighborhood policing in
areas with a high concentration of shops
and all too often that leads to well
people can you can call them customers
but in my view these are people who are
Taking Liberties um to be honest and
many businesses already feeling the
pinch because of the cost of living
crisis they're now having to deal with
this de facto
decriminalization where many shoplifters
to be honest get away with what they're
doing well that was the Curious Thing to
me because uh you you know how when
you're a kid you go to the playground
you get into you know scuff with another
kid or whatever your mom will be the one
telling you off and his mom will be the
one telling him off right what I found
odd about this is like this is someone
who's committing a
crime who is essentially a
representative of their Community by
virtue of their skin color it's
inevitable people will see it like that
what I find interesting is why the
community doesn't say well this person
is a criminal they don't represent us in
fact we're going to tell them off and
get them on the straight and narrow so
that people of our background aren't
stealing things from shops why is no one
having that conversation I think there
are some black British individuals who
did flag that but they weren't
especially high in number yeah and I
think what that really shows is that
there's a great deal of what to be
racial
tribalism but the the most tox the truly
toxic thing about this racial tribalism
is that you're ultimately asking for
preferential treatment over illegal
forms of you know forms of illegal
behavior and and I think what was quite
remarkable was how and by the way this
the lady in question behaved quite
aggressively towards the shopkeeper
before she was apprehended and by him
and I think it was just absolutely
remarkable that she was being portrayed
as the victim when she was engaging in
Behavior which was deeply
inappropriate and I I think that what
really concerns me is that you have
people who look to um
excuse um deeply inappropriate forms of
behavior because that particular person
might share their racial or ethnic
background and I think that's a very
serious problem I think that social
cohesion is at its healthiest and at it
Mo it strongest when people are willing
to face up to very uncomfortable
realities within their own racial ethnic
and religious communities and I think
that's something that I I have quite I'd
like to think I have quite an impressive
record on I've talk I've written a great
deal about islamist extremism and the
threat it poses to Modern Britain and
more widely um the Western world I've
also talked about attitudes towards
women in more closed off elements of
British Bangladeshi
communities um and that's not to say
there's not good going on in those
communities as well I've written a great
deal about that but I think if there's
if there problematic Trends within your
own racial ethnic and religious
community you you should flag them that
that that's the truth because other
people who may well see those Trends
they may feel uncomfortable they don't
want to be accused of being racist or
islamophobic um but I think you should
take it upon yourself and what I saw
with pekam actually you saw people
excusing this Behavior expressing solid
but what was really interesting you had
running me trust an organization I used
to respect a great deal when I was
growing up the so-called leading
independent race equality think tank in
the country expressing solidarity with
the lady um in that particular episode
The shoplifter yeah and and and I just
think that what about the Asian own what
the Asian own business what about the
Asian um business forget about
everyone's forget about everyone's race
what about expressing solidarity with
the shop owner whose shop is being
robbed absolutely and expressing
condemnation for the for the person
who's robbing the shop but the
shopkeeper also then the shopkeeper also
face racial discrimination which we
talked about as well so if you're the
leading independent race equality Think
Tank right I you'd at least flag those
issues those racist messages so reading
between the lines of all of this Ricky
what I'm hearing from you is you're
saying we've done really well but
actually one of the problems we are
having is inter ethnic minority tribal
absolutely conflict I think so and and I
think that and this is something that
hope not hate usually I'm not not the
biggest fan if truth be told but they
did do a really good study during the
pandemic which showed that ethnic ethnic
minorities are twice more likely to
agree than disagree with the statement
that social tensions are stronger
between ethnic minorities than between
non-white grp groups and the white
mainstream and so so I think many ethnic
minority people are fully aware of those
tensions between non-white groups you
saw in Leicester primarily between Hindu
and Muslim youths of South Asian origin
and I think that's the real problem and
I think that there's this import we
talking about importation of us racial
identity politics there's also an
importation of foreign territorial
disputes from the Middle East and the
Indian
subcontinent um communal tensions from
South Asia as well and that's very
troubling because what it does it
does if that's not addressed social
cohesion can unravel very quickly in the
more diverse parts of the country and
you were saying earlier about um
Singapore for example is very very
authoritarian when it comes to Law and
Order but say that's quite successful
multiethnic multifaith um democracy
which is very economically productive um
as well and I do think that in more
diverse parts of the country where
they're very competitive local economies
I do think you need strong localized Law
and Order just to keep things in check
and I think currently that's missing
from many parts of the country and it's
the other problem is is that we're just
not willing to talk about it because
when we talk about tensions we always
it's always white black white asian
absolutely it's very binary yeah and we
don't talk about this why don't we talk
about it I I think many people can't
comp they're not I don't think they
recognize it I don't think many people
can comprehend it they can't comprehend
that there may be racial tension
which don't involve white people and and
I think
that you know which coming from luten
and being raised there I find Bonkers
but many people are genuinely of that
mindset they're of that view or or
simply it could just be ignorance
they're not truly aware of it many you
know what I will tell you this until we
started the
show I not having not thought about it
very much believed there was such a
thing as the black community that it's a
myth yeah it's only when you start to oh
go wait afro Caribbean people are very
different to African people and and but
it's it's actually a form of I mean it's
not racism per se but it's a form of
ignorance about the complexity of all of
these it reminds me of a study that I
did a couple of years ago it showed that
one in SE six people of black Caribbean
origin have an unfavorable view of
people of black African origin yeah one
in six is quite High I mean it's around
16% and and I think that really shows
the tensions within the black British
population as well and and I think that
you know it's similar to black community
Muslim Community and people know that
that there's some denominational
tensions within the
British there's also ethnic tensions as
well and and and and there's also
there's also class related tensions
Within These so-called um communities so
and much of this is overlooked and I
think many people and I think I think
the import the the biggest problem is
really that there's many members of our
political
establishment they're either not
understanding of these Dynamics they
don't understand it or they know about
it but they don't want to raise it they
don't want to raise it because that
would mean they'd have some very UNC
they need to have some very
uncomfortable conversations in their
local sort of surgeries and all the rest
of it so they'd rather ignore it and
it's far easier just to talk about
racism and bigotry in the English
Countryside yeah and I remember once we
had a little boy in my class when I was
teaching and he was stealing that's what
he was doing it happens in school and I
remember uh my teaching assistant was
Nigerian and so we caught this boy and
we we gave him addressing down all the
rest of it so you shouldn't do this
brought Mom in had a chat right problem
was solved and I remember when he walked
out of my classroom once she just turned
around and looked to me and went this is
what congales people do
the teaching assistant not not the
mother not the mother no but the
teaching assistant said to me this the
Nigerian Heritage teaching ass saying
this is what congales people do they're
all thieves
and it doesn't also doesn't come as a
surprise to me though yeah it doesn't
come and and that's the thing even with
the The Wider black African category
you're talking about first gener you're
talking about you know first generation
wellestablished Christian migrants from
West Africa you're also talking about
you know maybe recently arrived refugees
who who follow Islam coming from
countries such as Somalia fleeing civil
unrest but they're all technically in
the same ethnic category yeah which is
incredibly diverse it it is it is and
really I think the problem comes as well
is then when you put identity Politics
on top of that it just toxify the whole
debate doesn't it because part of the
problem if we go back to pekam is that
people have seeing themselves as one
group against another group oh no no
absolutely and I I I have a um a black
friend of Nigerian origin he he talked
to me about
anti-blackness in South Asian
communities I said never mind
anti-blackness I mean you have some say
South Asian families they'll reject
their child's you know proposed choice
of marital spouse on on the grounds of
his or her skin color they might belong
to the same ethnic and racial group
they're not even interested in
understanding about their character
personality career vision for the future
you know if they if they're not happy
with their skin color oh you know I
don't want my grandchildren to be too
dark
these are the kind of sentiments that do
exist in modern Britain and these are
tensions within the same ethnic and
racial group so it doesn't come as a
surprise to me you're talking about the
Nigerian Heritage um teaching assistant
who unfortunately didn't have a high
opinion of people of congales origin it
just doesn't come as a surprise to me
because within the African continent you
know we not it can be incredibly the the
sort of tribal tensions you know
opinions of other people who may
originate from a different region
everyone hates their neighbors is quite
normal you know if you look around any
part of the world so so I think that
generally if you're talking about how
we're a relatively successful
multiracial democracy I would make that
point but I do think these kind of
tensions they're often overlooked and
they can't they are problems in terms of
you know so maintaining social cohesion
in hyper diverse areas many of our
politicians simply won't like to talk
about it because it's far easier just to
talk about um you know what White
Privilege or talk about racism in the
white British mainstream and often I'll
make and I'll make this point that some
of the sharpest social tensions in our
urban areas do not involve white British
people at all I think a lot of the
problem comes from the fact is that
we're not comfortable discussing issues
or problems that are actually live at
the moment it's far easier to talk about
issues or problems that that were more
relevant 40 years ago so for instance
about white supremacy of course there
are white supremacist still in this
country but if you think 40 years ago
when I grew up in South London there
were the NF there were the BMP these
people were mainstream they were outside
football matches handing out leaflets
the NF I don't think they even exist
anymore no I mean I think that I I'll
give you another example the University
of Leicester will be involved in a
project on Rural
racism and I just think did you not just
see what happened on your doorstep last
year I would have thought that you maybe
Focus your time energy and efforts on
communal tensions in Leicester in the
inner cities of Leicester seem to be
more focused on so-called racist
attitudes in the English Countryside and
Rural communities I just would think
that if University of Leicester they
would maybe have different priorities if
they wanted to do research if they
wanted to do work on how to maintain and
strengthen social cohesion they'd focus
more on what's going on on their
doorstep and I think it really shows
that it's it's comfort zone it's comfort
zone activity isn't it it's far easier
to talk about oh you know what's the
level of racism in blbe or ODB or this
or that and all the rest of it you know
the sort of more rural outskirts you
know rural parts of leerer as opposed to
actually talking about oh the spilling
of subcontinental style communalism on
the streets of an English Regional City
I would have thought they' have been
more likely to focus on that but then I
also know how far gone some elements of
the academic sector are on these kind of
issues and the problem is is that it's
almost impossible really for a white
upper middle class person to talk about
this because there's a very easy way to
shut them down and we know what that
word is and they can't take part in the
debate or the discussion yeah no I I
agree and I think that that's one of the
things I really don't like that you know
when we're having these debates on sort
of diversity equality and inclusion
they're actually deeply exclusionary of
um white men more generally I think it's
very interesting you saw that with the
Royal Air Force they wanted to boost the
diversity of the um you know a sort of
their recruitment they wanted to appeal
more to women and ethnic
minorities but in in doing so they
actually found they unlawfully
discriminating against white men and
there's one recruitment officer in the
RAF that referred to useless white male
Pilots a very specific form of
discrimination focused on race and sex
and and I think that what it really
shows I think that the diversity
politics in my view is incredibly
divisive as opposed to being inclusive I
think that is is hugely exclusionary and
I think that you and it's even things
like safe spaces which is very much an
import from the United States this is
modern day segregation and and you're
seeing that being proposed in Britain
and I I just don't want to see that take
root at all especially on University
campuses which I think is very much
focused on the sort of free flow of you
know different ideas information
exchange and all the rest of it for
students to be divided to talk about
sensitive matters of History to be
separated along racial lines I just
don't think that's right at all and
coming back to your point about
Community tensions between different
ethnic groups it sounds like what you
see as the answer to that is essentially
a a robust enforcement of the law
combined with Ane equality under the law
in other words it doesn't really matter
what your skin color is if you commit a
crime the police are going to be there
and they're going to deal with you is
that kind of no absolutely listen I I'll
make this point for example when I
talked about earlier about colorism
within South Asian communities
unfortunately you're just going to have
those kind of oldfashioned attitudes
among you know certain members of a
particular generation I'm not saying
that the police should get involved in
those issues but I think we should be
aware of that racism and bigotry can
exist in all sorts of communities I
think that's the point that I'd make and
I think that there's a concerted effort
to deflect attention away from those
problematic attitudes and I don't think
that's right um because I do think
sunlight is the best disinfectant I
think maybe if you expose those kind of
attitudes maybe you helped to facilitate
the social change that you'd like to see
so we're not talking about law order
enforcement in that area not in that era
but you're talking about clashes on the
street no no clashes on the street I'll
make that point with Leicester the local
constabulary there was woefully
underprepared for something like that
you had a lot of out of town
troublemakers as well from London and
Birmingham so we also have to to talk
about how are police force is
communicating with one another across
the country when it comes to those kind
of incidents so the reality if if you
are supportive of modern day diversity I
do think there has to be a degree of
conservatism when it comes to Law and
Order I think the issue that you have is
that you have a lot of pro diversity
Advocates and there something we haven't
talked about yet is immigration as well
I think that if you really want to
maintain high levels of social
solidarity in a multi-ethnic
multi-racial multiface society such as
ours
you need to reduce the pace of social
change that we're seeing in many parts
of the country and a lot of people think
God how could raket possibly say this he
Associates himself with the left I but I
also think that I also care about
sustaining the welfare state and the
reality is if you want to make sure that
you have uh all-encompassing well-funded
welfare state in place I think that you
need to have a stable National
membership and that requires having a
sensible and well ordered immigration
system I also think it means you need to
have an ass Asylum system which
prioritizes those who are very much in
need the world's most vulnerable peoples
we're not seeing that with the small
boats emergency on the English South
Coast that's very much male dominated I
think in the in
2022 two in three small boats migrants
were males aged 18 to 39 MH um many were
coming from countries such as Albania
Albania hasn't had a civil war since
1997 so so I think that what I'm
basically getting at is that in order to
have a truly successful democracy which
is diverse and advanced you need to be
conservative in certain areas namely
immigration and Law and Order and this
was always you know this was the left's
thing this was always what the left were
talking about projecting workers rights
by reducing immigration supply and
demand that's why there was that entire
branch of the left who voted for brexit
and also as well and this is what we
don't like to talk about but a lot of
immigrants
from my own family from immigrants that
I've spoken to not too keen on
immigration especially illegal IMM
they're noten on illegal immigration
because many went through the correct ke
on illegal immigration but I think the
point is that first generation migrants
may be especially sensitive to Illegal
immigation because they've gone through
the proper procedures we may even
included English language assessments
and they may have to have submitted
various forms of documentation before
legally relocating I I get triggered by
the concept that these people just think
oh yeah we should be people should be
allowed to come in illegally yeah so so
they they they they fulfilled their
obligations before legally relocating to
the UK right so when they see the scale
of illegal immigration on the English
South Coast they may well view it as a
form of Q jumping and they may be
especially sensitive to it and I think
more generally when it comes to
immigration um I wrote I wrote a piece
for unheard which I made the point that
it's actually labor Asian origin
heartlands who are ALS also quite
conservative when it comes to
immigration the majority of Voters in
those constituencies including mine of
luta North they think immigration is too
high yeah and and I think the the idea
that conservative attitudes towards
immigration are The Preserve of white
Brits well sorry you didn't understand
brexit very well either what was very
interesting is that you saw these London
based journalists after brexit oh God we
need to find some brexit voters God
where are they where do I find them they
go to pubs in northern England they go
to working Men's Clubs in the provincial
Midlands all you have to do is go to
some of the Mund mundas and garas in
West London You' have found your fair
share of leave voters right there and I
think it's a fundamental misunder
understanding of many people couldn't
comprehend how brexit even took place
but some of the most conservative
attitudes that I've come across towards
immigration law and order Asylum as well
they come from established migrant
communities and I think that's something
that's not talked about all that much
but it makes complete sense because when
you think about they look at it go look
I came here as an immigrant I worked
really hard I paid into the system I set
up a business I've raised a family
absolutely and then there's people
coming here on boats and they they're
not going through any of that no they're
just turning up absolutely and I would
make the point why would a female
Refugee who is fleeing you know a a part
of the world where rape was a weapon of
War um why would they express solidarity
with many of the male illegal migrants
entering on the English South Coast just
because they're Refugee there's no
reason and actually they may feel even
more sensitive to that as well because
they would have felt that list I I fled
very direct forms direct threats of
persecution and violence um and sexual
violence in my homeland and this is how
this is why odds granted Refugee states
in the UK why would they express
solidarity with the illegal migrants on
the English South Coast there's no
reason for them to in fact they may be
more sensitive to that so I think that
with with labor more generally and I I
made no secret that I still tradition
traditionally I associate myself with
the labor party I'm from a labor voting
Town traditionally labor voting town in
Luton one of the first things I did when
I finally entered the world of work was
join a trade Union but I think that you
make such a good point about workers
rights because when people think about
workers rights for some reason they
think that's a form of xenophobia but
British workers are of different races
ethnicities and faiths we have a very
multi multi-ethnic multifaith
um Workforce now so I I think that what
I'd like to see is of course you need a
dynamic immigration system which
addresses urgent shortages in the labor
market but I think that what would be
quite an attractive and electorally
popular policy is investing more in the
domestic Workforce you know in sort of
improving um skills the provision of
high quality apprenticeships in
working-class communities and that's not
only going to benefit white British
people that'll benefit a variety of
people and then over time the country
can wean itself off immigration
dependency especially especially in
sectors such as Health and Social care
riie it's great to have you on the show
the book is called Beyond grievance make
sure to get it we're going to head over
to locals for your questions in a second
but before we do we always end with the
same question which is what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should be I think the one thing
we're not talking about as much as we
should is um prejudiced attitudes within
minority communities we just did an hour
of that well well one thing we didn't
touch upon was that I didn't talk
specifically about anti-Semitism which
you know actually when you're looking at
British Muslim and British black
communities levels of anti-Semitism and
belief in anti-semitic conspiracy
theories actually higher than the
general population and I think that's
something that labor especially with its
recent record especially under Jeremy
Corbin along with the fact that it does
command a high level of you know uh
public support among British Muslim and
British black communities more generally
it's something that they may well have
to face up to at some point I think
you're' being very unfair CU Dian
Abbott's been very strong on
this no but it always makes me laugh
when these like left liberal newspapers
write these outraged articles about
Rising levels of anti-Semitism like why
don't you do a little digging and find
out where it's coming from yeah uh
anyway Rak thank you so much for coming
on uh head on over to locals where we
continue the
conversation why is ethnic diversity
seen as a cause for problems in Africa
in the Middle East but a strength uh
where diversities are strength in the
West
[Music]